[Music]
Asch Carlson here out front of Museum of
pop culture out here in Seattle and we
are getting an exclusive sneak preview
of the new Marvel Universe of superheros
exhibit it's over 10,000 square feet and
over 300 artifacts props and
never-before-seen pages I am so excited
clearly let's go check it out the rarest
beast is an issue of Marvel Comics
number one
so the first Marvel comic book was just
called Marvel comics and honestly even a
month ago we didn't big was gonna happen
the last minute it all came together so
that was cool would you be willing to
just give give us a tour of the entire
exhibit right now let's take a look all
right we're gonna give you guys an early
preview let's do it going in here it is
Marvel Comics issue number one featuring
the Human Torch who is a different Human
Torch than the one we get to know later
and in Fantastic Four this this Human
Torch was actually an Android it could
kind of get super hot shoot flame and
melty things the Fantastic Four is
another big landmark in Marvel's history
in the late 50s early 60s the comics
industry was is in decline mm-hmm paper
costs were going up television was
really competing the people's attention
to what kind of pop culture they would
be absorbing and the story is that Stan
Lee was was a little burned out and
thinking he would get out of the
business and again the story goes that
his wife said to him or looking you're
done with this why don't you just write
the comic you boys wanted to write just
whatever you feel like
don't be constrained and he injected we
created the Fantastic Four huge hit and
really revitalized the comics industry
and Marvel come and take pics with them
like this we talked about the Black
Panther sort of through time how he
started out the original idea was
pulling the coal tiger and this is his
his first sort of costume design this
got scrapped but later the coal tiger
rapture came back in the comics as a
separate person for life
the Black Panther had to deal with but I
mean first appeared and Fantastic Four
what I love about modern film costumes
is because of of high definition and
things like that they have to be super
detailed down to the every little bead
every little thread and in the movies it
just tends to like fly box right right
and this is an opportunity to sit if
you're interested and like study study
the work Cherie is definitely a favorite
this is a page of original artwork from
the short story which was an amazing
fantasy 15 which was spider-man's origin
story there is no original art remaining
for any other Marvel major superhero
so Iron Man's origin story original art
gone all these folks only spider-man's
or origin story remains an original art
by these costume from spider-man
homecoming and I you know to me this is
super emblematic of what's by the Rings
about the homemade costume with the
hoodie and the and the drawn spider and
the goggles and stuff Wow 10 years of
Iron Man began it's that opportunity to
look at of course the detail and see how
the artists and weathered it and they
imply welding and cap yeah whoo I think
even more than Iron Man the Captain
America stories started to draw a wider
audience into the Marvel film
hooked on a feelin sweet 1973 that song
belongs to me okay I've been feeling
sure it is yeah beautiful maquette have
grouped so this is was created by
artists to venues as a study object for
the CG artists to make the
computer-generated group but look up
there so boots started as a monster sort
of monster of the week in the early
comic used this tree monster the x-men
were another era area where Marvel was
kind of digging into issues and they use
the expended with metaphor for
difference and could tell stories about
persecution or about discrimination the
original art from the cover of Wolverine
number one and then also number two it's
just so cool to see it all pasted kind
of together okay I know where we're
going I can already tell oh it's about
to get mystical
Wow this is really cool my man's right
here
unfortunately Benedict isn't but the
costume is look at that cloak not a cape
the eye of agamotto sitting on top we
talk about what we're calling the
street-level heroes okay
so especially a lot of the folks that
are getting expressed in television
today people like Jessica Jones and Luke
Cage and daredevil this is the very
first sketch by John Romita of The
Punisher like they were trying to
develop the character and you can see
they're trying out the name is like the
Grim Reaper the executioner they weren't
good this is where we talk about how
Marvel has so wonderfully in
delightfully interacted with its fans
over the years this is one of my
favorites here this is the page from
Fantastic Four and you can see it says
to Neal a full front face er Stanley so
there are six levels of fandom official
fandom Marvel and full front face er is
the top level which can only be bestowed
by Stanley himself on a fan individually
so involved being knighted yeah yeah
okay so we've spent the day learning
about all these characters learning more
about them than we already knew and now
I have to pick a favorite come on
[Music]
it's very hard but I gotta go for my
baby now he's got 10 votes wow he's
really we got we've got a pool one out
for strange here you guys haven't opened
yet so once you guys open all the
strange votes will come thank you so
much for giving us this amazing tour
I've learned so much about Marvel that I
didn't previously know so that's good
and you guys watching if you want to
come check it out for yourself that's
April 21st here at the Museum of pop
culture in Seattle
[Music]
[Applause]